le ministe la parole et à mesure
françois de mazières merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre la culture la communication
20 ministres lundi vous avez signé avec
la président directeur général de france
télévisions
le contrat d'objectifs et de moyens pour
la période jusqu'à 2020 ce contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens prévoit une
augmentation des aides de l'état de 63
millions d'euros dont 38 millions
d'euros pour le seul budget 2010 est et
si l'on regarde pourquoi cette
augmentation des dépenses de l'état
c'est essentiellement pour la création
de la chaîne france ô d'info en continu
france info vous avez prévu une création
de 75 emplois nouveaux
sur un total de 150 emplois la question
que les français peuvent se poser c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire des
économies partout il faut se serrer la
ceinture et il souffre des augmentations
notamment de la fiscalité
alors on peut se dire pourquoi créer un
nouveau service est ce qu'il n'y avait
pas assez de chaînes aujourd'hui alors
que l'offre est pléthorique
alors qu'il y à trois chaînes
d'information en continu ces chaînes
sont certes privée mais elles sont de
qualité
benjamin ministre on a bien vu que le
succès n'est pas vraiment là puisque
aujourd'hui l'audience de cette nouvelle
chaîne c'est 0,3 pour cent un taux très
faible et même les salariés de la radio
france info se sont mis en grève parce
qu'ils ne sont pas favorables ce projet
alors madame agnès en question est
simple est-ce que vous pensez vraiment
que les chaînes d'info continue privé
était de qualité si médiocre qu'il
fallait faire une nouvelle chaîne au
corps ou est ce que c'est la bière de
noël vous êtes sonne le syndrome des
cadeaux et vous en faites beaucoup
actuellement
la parole est à madame audrey azoulay
ministre de la culture et de la
communication merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député
françois de mazières je voudrais
commencer simplement ma réponse à cette
question par un hommage à rémy pflimlin
qui a dirigé france télévisions après
avoir dirigé france 3 et qui nous a
quittés récemment j'ai signé
effectivement lundi dernier après de
longues négociations et un processus qui
a bien entendu concerné les commissions
de l'assemblée et du sénat un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens avec france
télévisions avec effectivement et vous
pouvez le constater un gros contraste
par rapport à ce qui prévalait jusqu'à
je rappellerai que l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public a été restauré là
où la nomination avait été confisqué au
csa lui a été restituée et nous avons
aussi donné une feuille de route
stratégique et financière au groupe
public dans les moyens qui ont été
donnés à france télévisions dans ce
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
il y a trois priorités et non pas une
seule trois priorités la première vous
l'avez dit c'est la création la création
avec un engagement de financement annuel
de france télévisions dans nos
programmes les documentaire et la
fiction l'animation le cinéma un
engagement qui rôdent qui est relevé de
400 à 420 millions d'euros c'était la
première priorité la deuxième vous
l'avez souligné c'est l'information mais
l'information les chiffres que vous avez
ne sont pas exacts mais je me ferai un
plaisir de vous les communiquer de
nouveau puisque le chiffre de vous savez
que le projet de la chaîne d'information
qui est un service aussi numérique est
constitué par la mutualisation de moyens
et que le coût supplémentaire est de
l'ordre de 15 millions d'euros
et enfin la troisième priorité c'est le
numérique afin d'assurer l'avenir du
groupe france télévision je crois que
nous avons une vision du service public
qui dans la société qui est la nôtre qui
est une société fragmentée
nous défendons à la fois son
indépendance son rôle fédérateur est
aussi une priorité stratégique pour les
programmes qui font l'imaginaire
collectif de la société et qu'il ne faut
absolument pas d'éléments